N
TO WHAT YOUR KIDS SEE ONLINE.
"THE GREG GUTFELD SHOW" NEXT.
>> CHOCOLATE OR VANILLA.
>> VANILLA IS JUST SORT OF A
DISAPPOINTING CHOCOLATE.
>> GREG: WOW!
[CHEERS]
>> GREG: ALL RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN MAY HAVE DISCOVERED
THE SECRET TO TIME TRAVEL.
HEAR ME OUT.
WE'RE CURRENTLY SEEING THE
MIDDLE EAST UNRAVEL FASTER THAN
ILHAN'S MARRIAGE TO HER BROTHER.
WE'RE SEEING AN SURD -- AN
ABSURD GAS SHORTAGE AND HIGH GAS
PRICES.
WE HAVE A BUMBLING LEADERS WHO
SCARES NO ONE SUCH SOMEONE WHO
USES HERBAL ESSENCE SHAMPOO.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS RISING AS
BENEFITS KEEP FLOWING.
CRIME IS BACK AND BLOODIER THAN
EVER.
WE'RE WITNESSING SHOOTINGS AND
MURDERS LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
NOT EXACTLY LIKE NEVER BEFORE.
WE HAVE SEEN IT BEFORE.
IN FACT, WE'VE SEEN IT ALL
BEFORE.
IT'S CALLED -- ♪
♪ WE'LL BE MAKING ANOTHER RUN ♪
♪ THE 17 S
-- THE ♪
♪ DON'T LEAVE HOME WITHOUT A
GUN ♪
♪ THERE IS NO GAS ♪
♪ INFLATION WILL LEAVE YOU
BROKE ON YOUR ASS ♪
♪ THE 70s WE'RE ALL GOING TO
HELL THE '70s ♪
♪ THE '70s ♪
[SIREN]
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: YOU DON'T HAVE TO CLAP.
THAT WAS NO JACK JONES.
BUT IT'S TRUE.
WE'VE GONE BACK TO THE '70s, A
10-YEAR SPAN SO AWFUL WE HAD TO
CREATE THE 1980s AND 1990s TO
ERASE IT.
ON THE PLUS SIDE, WE MIGHT GET
ANOTHER ONE OF THESE.
MAYBE WE HAVE.
SERIOUSLY.
SHE IS THIS GENERATION'S FARRAH
FAWCETT OR JACQUELINE SMITH.
I CAN'T MAKE UP MY MIND, BUT WHY
SHOULD I?
IT'S NOT LIKE I'M STALKING YOU,
KAITLIN, OKAY?
YOU DM'D ME FIRST AND THEN I
FIGURED I SHOULD START WORKING
MY MAGIC ON YOU, AND THEN SHE
GHOSTS ME AND GOES ON HANNITY.
YOU STILL DATE WOMEN, WHATEVER.
I FELT LIKE I WAS LET ON AND IT
KIND OF HURTS.
JUST LIKE THE '70s.
THE CRIME, JOBLESSNESS, THE
TURMOIL, AN UNSTABLE WORLD
QUESTIONING AMERICA'S
RESILIENCE, AND ALSO, NO
COINCIDENCE, JOE BIDEN IS IN
D.C.
THE FACT IS, WE'RE LEARNING A
HARSH LESSON THAT PROGRESS,
STABILITY AND SUCCESS IS JUST
ONE LIBERAL AWAY FROM DISASTER.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
EVERYTHING GREAT ABOUT AMERICA
CAN BE UNRAVELED BY ONE LEFTIST
WITH SOME POWER AND A VENDETTA
AGAINST AMERICA AND WE HAVE AN
ADMINISTRATION CRAWLING WITH
THEM.
TAKE NEW YORK.
RUDY GIULIANI TOOK A CITY WITH
RAMPANT CRIME AND TURNED IT INTO
A NUMBER ONE TOURIST ATTRACTION.
THEN BLOOMBERG INHERITED IT AND
DIDN'T SCREW IT UP TOTALLY, AND
THEN THIS GUY CAME ALONG, A
GROUNDHOG MURDERING IDIOT SO
CLUELESS THAT HE MIGHT ACTUALLY
BE FROM ANOTHER PLANET.
I THINK THEY CALL IT SATURN.
MADE UP OF PARTS FROM LESSER
IDIOTS AND IT TOOK ONLY ONE
CARD-CARRYING ANTI-CARRYING --
NOW GOTHIC CITY.
JOE BIDEN WAS SO NOSTALGIC WHEN
HE HAD REAL HAIR THAT HE TOOK US
BACK THERE IN A MATTER OF RUNS.
IT'S A PATTERN.
THE ATTENTION SPAN OF FRUIT
FLIES WITH IQ'S LOWER THAN CNN'S
RATINGS, LIVE TO SEE THE
PROGRESS MADE BY REPUBLICANS AS
WRONG AND THEREFORE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPERIMENT.
AND WE ARE THEIR GUINEA PIGS.
OUR JOBS, OUR HEALTHCARE, OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM AND IT'S THOSE
EXPERIMENTS THAT LEAD TO THE
DEVASTATION.
IT'S A CYCLE.
LIBERALS LIKE SPOILED CHILDREN
RUIN THINGS WHICH REPUBLICANS
LIKE PATIENT PARENTS FIX AND
THAT CREATES A FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY THAT ALLOWS LIBERALS TO
RETURN AND RUIN THEM AGAIN.
I SAY WE PUT THEM UP FOR
ADOPTION SO WE CAN HAVE NICE
THINGS IN THE HOUSE AGAIN.
I WONDER WHAT THE ANGRY WHITE
MALE THINKS?
♪
IT'S LIKE THE AMERICA I GREW UP
IN.
URBAN DECAY.
CRIME.
INFLATION.
GAS LINES.
DEMOCRATS.
YOU MAKE ME FEEL YOUNG AGAIN.
[APPLAUSE]
>> GREG: CAN WE TIME TRAVEL OUT
OF THIS MESS?
MAYBE IF WE DIDN'T HAVE SO MANY
OPTIONS FOR ENTERTAINMENT.
BACK IN THE 1970s WE HAD THREE
CHANNELS.
WE HAD ALMOST NO OPTIONS FOR
PORN.
UNLESS YOU COUNT THE SEXY INDIAN
GIRL ON THE LAND-O-LAKES BOX.
SOMETIMES WE WENT TO THE SEARS
CATALOG WITH AN ERASER.
NO ONE UNDERSTANDS THAT.
WE CRIMINALIZE POT, KEEPS US
AMBIVALENT.
THE WHOLE WORLD OUTSIDE COULD
CRUMBLE BUT WE'RE TOO HAPPY
BINGE WATCHING.
THE QUESTION IS, FOR HOW LONG?
THANK GOD I STILL HAVE THIS.
DON'T WORRY, I LAMINATED IT.
[APPLAUSE]
>> WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE'S SO COUNTRY, HE THINKS A
SEVEN COURSE MEAL IS A POSITIVE
SUM AND A KISSBACK.
SONGWRITER LARRY GATLIN.
WHEN HE TELLS A JOKE, THE WOKE
SHALL CHOKE.
PODCAST COMEDIAN -- STAND UP
COMIC.
WHO NEEDS A BOOSTER SEAT.
AND SHE SAID TILL DEATH DO US
PART AND NOW HER HUSBAND IS
MISSING.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT.
I'M EXCITED.
LARRY, I'VE GOT THREE QUESTIONS
FOR YOU.
ONE, DO YOU REMEMBER THE '70s?
TWO, DO YOU REMEMBER JIMMY
CARTER, AND THREE, DO YOU
REMEMBER DOING COKE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE?
.
>> I THOUGHT TONIGHT WAS GOING
TO BE A CAREER MOVE.
I DON'T THINK IT TURNED OUT THAT
WAY.
IF YOU REMEMBER THE NOT '70s,
YOU WEREN'T A PART OF IT.
WHAT WAS THE SECOND QUESTION.
>> JIMMY CARTER.
>> WE WERE FRIENDS.
HE WAS A NICE MAN.
IN MY OPINION, IF ANYONE WAS
EVER, YOU KNOW, NOT REALLY UP TO
THE TASK OF THAT, THAT WOULD BE,
IF YOU PUT IT IN THE DICTIONARY
AND ILLUSTRATE IT.
GOOD MAN, POLICIES ALL WRONG,
AND DIE REMEMBER SNORTING COKE?
I HAVE KIDS AND GRANDKIDS.
>> GREG: SO YOU'RE SAYING YOU
DON'T REMEMBER?
>> HEY, IT JUST SEEMED LIKE THE
THING TO DO.
AHAD SOME HELP -- STEPHEN
STEELS.
-- I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> STEVEN STILLS' SON.
>> THAT'S THE MOST INSIDIOUS
DRUG ON THE PLANET.
>> I WOULDN'T DISAGREE.
>> LET ME GIVE YOU, THE TEST,
THEY WOULD PUT LITTLE MONKEYS IN
THE CAGE AND THE LITTLE MONKEYS,
THEY TEACH THEM TO SELF-INDUCE
AND BOUNCE UP AGAINST THIS
NEEDLE.
THE LITTLE GUY MONKEYS, IF GIVEN
A CHOICE TO GET NEXT TO A LITTLE
GIRL MONKEY OR TO GET THE
COCAINE, WHICH ONE DO YOU THINK
THEY TOOK?
>> KAITLIN JENNER?
>> NO.
THEY TOOK THE COCAINE EVERY
TIME.
IT'S INSIDIOUS.
>> BUT THOSE MONKEYS WERE IN A
BAND.
>> THEY RAN OUT, YOU KNOW.
SO IT WAS CRAZY.
IT JUST SEEMED LIKE THE THING TO
DO.
THE '70s.
SO STEPHEN -- NOBODY WAS DOWN
THERE SO WE JUST WENT IN THE
LIBRARY, REST ROOM.
>> GREG: NICK, THIS IS GOOD NEWS
FOR EVERYBODY BECAUSE IF WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK TO THE '70s,
THAT MEANS WE'RE ALL DOING COKE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> IT WASN'T A WHITE HOUSE, IT
WAS A HOLIDAY INN.
LOUDOUN COUNTY.
>> GREG: SO IT'S ONLY BEEN 100
SOME ODD DAYS AND EVERYBODY IS
GOING TO HELL IN A HAND BASKET.
>> IS THAT A SURPRISE?
TRUMP CALLED EVERYTHING THAT
WE'RE GOING THROUGH.
I WANT TO YELL AT PEOPLE WHO
VOTED FOR BIDEN, BUT WE KNOW
NOBODY DID.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT HERE'S THE THING.
THAT'S MY OPINION, NOT FOX'S.
JIMMY CARTER, LIKE HE SAID, I
MET HIM ON THE "TONIGHT" SHOW.
HE WAS A HORRIBLE POLITICIAN BUT
BIDEN IS INFLICTING THIS PAIN
INTENTIONALLY.
WE KNOW IT'S AOC AND BERNIE AND
THE REST OF THE IDIOTS.
>> HE'S A HOLLOW VESSEL.
IF HE DOESN'T DO WHAT THEY SAY
THEY DON'T GIVE HIM THE PUDDING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> I JUST WANT TO GO TO PULLED.
>> GREG: WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
ON THIS THEORY THAT WE'RE
RETURNING TO THE ERA KNOWN AS
THE 1970s?
YOU GREW UP IN THE 1970s, RIGHT?
>> LITTLE BIT.
>> I WAS VERY COKED UP AS A
CHILD.
YES, IT'S DEFINITELY THE '70s
SHOW.
THAT'S WHAT WE HAVE WITH BIDEN.
IT REALLY FEELS LIKE A
THROWBACK, TOO, BECAUSE WE'RE
SAYING THING LIKE, IS JENNER
GOING TO RUN?
>> OH, I GET IT.
>> I KNOW YOU WERE SICK EARLIER.
>> YES, IF I WORKED IN THE U.S.
EMBASSY SOMEWHERE, I WOULD PACK
THE BAG BECAUSE THINGS ARE GOING
TO GET BAG.
IT'S UNFORTUNATE.
YOU LOOK AT SOMEBODY LIKE, THEY
DON'T SEEM TO UNDERSTAND THAT
THE POLICIES THAT ARE BAD HAVE
BAD CONSEQUENCES.
IT SEEMS TO BAFFLE THEM AND THEN
YOU SEE deBLASIO AND HIS WIFE ON
NEW YEAR'S EVE DANCING AT AN
EMPTY TIMES SQUARE, "I AM
LEGEND."
MEANWHILE, HE PUT HER IN CHARGE
OF A CHARITY THAT HAS $800
MILLION UNACCOUNTED FOR.
>> GREG: EXACTLY.
>> THE MONEY WENT IN AND NOTHING
CAME OUT.
>> GREG: I DON'T EVEN THINK
LARRY COULD SPEND ALL OF THAT ON
COKE.
>> I TRIED.
I TRIED.
>> GREG: SO KAT, TALK ABOUT THE
TRADE-OFF BEFORE THE ELECTION,
WHICH PEOPLE WERE WILLING TO
VOTE TRUMP OUT OF OFFICE FOR HIS
MEAN TWEETS AND SO WHAT YOU'VE
GOT IN EXCHANGE, AND THAT
WORKED.
NO MORE MEAN TWEETS BUT
NEWFOUNDLAND GOT INFLATION,
UNEMPLOYMENT, THE MIDDLE EAST,
SO NOW ALL THE NEWS ANCHORS CAN
SLEEP BETTER AT NIGHT BECAUSE
TRUMP DOESN'T HURT THEIR
FEELINGS BUT THE REST OF US ARE
ALL SCREWED.
>> THE NEWS ANCHORS ARE
COMPLICIT IN ALL OF THIS.
THE GOVERNMENT IS SAYING, IT'S
NO BIG DEAL.
LIKE THE GAS THING, DON'T PANIC,
IT'S NO BIG DEAL.
HOW IS NOT BEING ABLE TO LEAVE
YOUR HOUSE IN A BIG DEAL?
PETE BUTTIGIEG MAY NOT HAVE THIS
BUT WITH ALL THE CRISIS THAT HE
HAD 20 TO FACE IN SOUTH BEND,
INDIANA, THEY ARE STUCK AT HOME,
CAN'T GO TO WORK, BUT THEY GET
THE GOVERNMENT PAYMENTS, STAY
HOME, ENVIRONMENT IS NOT
EFFECTED, SO IT'S NOT A PROBLEM
IF YOU TRUE WORLD IN A CERTAIN
WAY WHERE INDIVIDUALS AREN'T
RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING CARE OF
THEMSELVES.
I'M ALWAYS RESPONSIBLE F